in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Andy
and Brooke are with us hey guys how are
ya
welcome welcome where y'all from Akron
Pennsylvania cool welcome to Nashville
and here to do a debt-free scream yes so
how much have you paid off a little over
70,000 very cool I love it
and how long did that take you it took
it was a span of six years and there's
reasons for that I guess we'll get into
when we share our story okay and income
during range during that time we went
from 40 to approximately 88 okay very
cool good for you way to go way to go
way to go so tell me the story then
what's the what's the what's the journey
like well uh several years ago we ended
up purchasing some homes on a home and a
kind of credit for rental properties and
of course the market took a crash of
course and we tried to ride that out and
didn't want to go down the foreclosure
or any of that at route but that's where
we ended up going mmm so we could save
our home and so that process took some
time we were stuck in the small home
that we've we had for almost 13 years
and in the process we heard about you
and we start looking at what debts we
did have and here we are married or
spring we took our we took our first fu
class about six years ago and a few
months before we took that class we had
purchased our a newer vehicle of course
on a monthly payment plan this is pre
Dave Ramsey and when once we finished
the class we realized that we didn't
want to be debt free or we wanted to be
debt-free and we want to pursue that
journey so we sort of rode the wave we
were committed but not a hundred percent
and then one day I was in the office
paying bills and I looked at our home
equity line of credit bill and I was
like well this thing hasn't gone down at
all what's going on here so I called and
and I realized the big mistake we made
is this line of credit we took out on a
insurance only payment plan and and I
iced my heart
just some interest only interest only
sorry interest only payment my heart
sunk more at our stupidity than anything
we I'm like how can we have been so
stupid so that was $36,000 and we nailed
that out in 23 months we did have a six
thousand dollar gift from somebody but
the 30,000 we paid off in 23 months and
then from there to now we just plowed
through it boom now if you paid off your
first mortgage as well we sold our home
our first home back in October and we
just purchased a new home in December
then okay and then we had a seven
thousand dollar tax bill come up this
this past tax season we paid that off
and since then you know we're officially
debt-free except for a house and I lay
that off quickly hello and see you went
through Financial Peace University six
years ago and that starts this whole
journey yep Wow and you've been
coordinating the class I understand yes
and how many classes have you
coordinated I think we guessed about
fifteen or sixteen classes we did and
you're like professional yeah Wow
so why would mean so you've used that
class just to keep you going to haven't
you absolutely it's huge help every time
we coordinate it's you know we're at a
different step in our journey we see
things differently we hear things
differently and it just keeps keeps
pushing us along inspires you along
along with you've got great stories for
your classes absolutely Wow well thank
you for doing that with such diligence
Wow we're honored very very neat very
fun I'm so proud of you guys thank you
it's a long journey was it worth it
absolutely man yeah god I think he just
blessed our efforts more than we ever
could have imagined yeah I mean cuz
you've been through the wringer I mean
you've been through everything here
that's a lot of miles and secure yeah it
really is I had to stick with it for six
years that's very cool
so now that you're old time big time
coordinators teaching the class sixteen
times and you're debt-free the next
class somebody's gonna be in there and
they're gonna be scared and they're
gonna where they're gonna be belligerent
or they're gonna be something and
they're gonna ask that question so how
did you get out of that what do you tell
them the keys are we wrote it down rice
and beans and beans are
saying no to a lot of a lot of great
things that come along friends and
family want to do vacations this this is
our first family vacation we made it
ever here ever ever and how long have
y'all been married 13 years and our kids
our oldest is almost 10 and never taking
a family week-long vacation here you're
in Nashville well we're honored to have
you
very neat so the kids names and ages are
what our oldest son is MacGyver he will
be 10 in just a few weeks next is
maverick he is 8 and our daughter is 4
and her name is Kaylie onna ok are they
gonna help us with a debt-free screen
okay guys get them into the camera now
we're gonna give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's book retire inspired because
that's the next step baby step for now
you're debt-free if the emergency fund
in place and now you're ready to go I
mean so you're ready to go off and be
retire inspired and live like no one
else so that later you could live and
give like no one else I'm so proud of
you guys congratulations and thank you
thank you thank you for teaching the
class and being such a blessing to so
many families I'm hearing 160 hundred 80
families over 16 classes wow that's a
lot that's amazing probably 200 I mean
there's no telling how many people in
there that's amazing so congratulations
all right Andy Brooke MacGyver maverick
and Kate kalyana count it down
Philadelphia is $70,000 paid off in six
years count it down let's hear your debt
free scream three two one
Wow way to go you guys way to go man
that is awesome hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind